strength at the basket garland up top
for allen boy it sounded like there was
a slab here
going nuts lebron the other way in
toward prince lays it up and in
it was a slap you could hear it all the
way up here
morris james kuzma harrell and matthews
are on the floor for the lakers lebron
once again to the bucket
he now has 29 and his lakers are back on
top
you've got to continue to defend him did
the cavs let him get down
so close to the basket he's too big for
that you got
boy i'll tell you you can't you've got
to play smarter than this
back to davis it goes hesitates fires a
high arcing triple
tapped a number of times mcgee grabs it
mcgee tried to feed akoro knocked away
by lebron
lebron to the bucket lays it in under
five to go in regulation caldwell pope
couldn't get drummond to fight back to
lebron he's got a hurry long distance
three
got it wow this is the drama drummond
put it up blocked from behind by davis
out come the lakers with a five-point
lead the little things
the little things is what they do so
well i mean
they they they do the little things all
the time
trying to get inside
davis blocks it from behind and then
lebron
down the lane for two
james you're gonna shoot this started by
okoro step back three
now davis 100 seconds to go in
regulation
watch by allen gives it to james
james for three
this was the previous triple by james
got that big davis screen
and then this one from the corner this
will tell you the entire story actually
that's the same one
we approach the one minute mark draws a
double allen's out there
and lebron from the corner he cannot
miss
here tonight what more can you say to
this allen came with the
a double away from 22 feet
wow